[Music]
the recent arrival of the long-awaited
spider-man no way home was thrilling for
many reasons but the promise of seeing
more than one of spidey's biggest foes
joined the marvel cinematic universe for
the first time arguably had fans more
excited than any other aspect of its
release ever since alfred molina
revealed that he was reprising the role
of dark ark a character he first
portrayed in sam raimi's spider-man 2 in
2004 franchise devotees began to eagerly
anticipate the chance to see he and
various villains from the other
spider-man films take on tom holland's
peter parker jamie foxx's electro is one
of the antagonists from a prior
spider-man movie who made their mcu
debut in no way home electro first
appeared on the big screen in
the amazing spider-man 2. though the
film was considered one of the worst to
start the fame to webslinger elektro was
certainly a memorable villain making his
reintroduction in the latest spider-man
film a welcome inclusion in spite of the
poor reception of his first film
appearance with that said the actor
recently revealed that he initially felt
hesitant to reprise the role prior to
accepting and would only return if one
condition in particular was met first
mcu architect kevin feige and sony
producer amy pascal recently sat down
with brandon davis from comicbook.com
and amidst the discussion of various
other topics related to spider-man no
way home the trio eventually got to
talking about electro when the character
first appeared in the amazing spider-man
2 many fans were upset by the
character's full body spanning electric
blue color which was a far cry from his
look in the comics however trailers for
spider-man no way home revealed that in
his latest film electro would be
outfitted in a costume much more akin to
how the character appeared in his comic
book source material a costume which
also features an iron man arc reactor
this subject came up when davis asked
feige if electro lost his blue
appearance because of that arc reactor
feige a veteran when it comes to
avoiding spoiling his own movies replied
i won't say that you're wrong i also
won't say that you're right he did share
however that the studios promised thugs
that electro wouldn't be blue this time
around fox himself has publicly shared
his distaste for the blue costume
speaking at the cc xp panel he expressed
his enthusiasm for the new take on the
character in the mcu saying he was
excited for the change electro is one of
the more sympathetic spider-man villains
and the comic accurate revision to his
appearance in no way home indicates
marvel's commitment to bringing this
character to life the right way
following the release of spider-man no
way home on december 17th jamie foxx
further discussed returning to the role
of electro in an interview published on
the official marvel website after fox
reiterated that the promise of the
character sporting a new appearance
contributed to him accepting the role he
went on to explain how elektro's
acknowledgment of his new look in the
movie script was integral to pulling off
such a drastic alteration to his
previously established character fox
said the biggest thing that changed is
that he acknowledged the way he looked
he acknowledged oh i like this i dig
this by doing that it answers any
questions like why or what's this thing
being able to do that and just bringing
a little of the way i wanted to talk and
how i wanted to present myself elektro
has a little hipness to him foxx had
further kind things to say about his
character's new look in response to a
question about the fact that his updated
costume resembles an electrician's
uniform it's electrician chic what i'm
saying is that it's fly it's not a cape
or anything like that i really dug that
that's cool because it keeps it
practical practical magic is what you
could call it because he's so practical
so while he appears to have disliked the
look of the character the first time
around fox offered nothing but praise
for both the process through which the
character was redesigned and the
appearance they ultimately landed on
during the production of no way home
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
no way home are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
you